Let's take a quick tour through appearances on
right wing media and by Republican politicians
over the last 24 hours or so, the big news, of
course, we covered it at the top of the show
was that with absolutely zero Republican support
in the Senate, Democrats passed a one point nine
trillion dollar stimulus bill, which, while not as
big as we want, not as soon as we wanted, doesn't
include the minimum wage. It will put thousands of
dollars in the pockets of families with children.
It will provide a ton of money to accelerate
vaccination. And it was all done without a
single Republican supporting it. A great question
for these Republican elected officials would be,
you know, a lot of your constituents want this
bill and yet you voted against it. That was not
the story on right wing media for the 24 for the
last 24 hours. What is the right been up to over
this period of time? Let's take a look. First
example here is Mississippi Governor Tate Reeves,
who recently canceled all covid guidelines. Wide
open state, no more masking nothing. Tate Reeves
went on CNN and still in nearly the middle of
March, would not acknowledge that Joe Biden
simply won the election. Take a look at this.
Do you accept that Joe Biden is the legitimate,
lawfully accepted, lawfully elected
president of the United States?
President Biden is the president of the United
States, but was he legitimate? We don't allow in
voting. In our state, we do not allow mail
in voting, and the reason we don't allow
mail in voting is because we don't think
that we think that it allows for lots of
opportunities for fraud and other things.
And I don't think mail in voting should be
allowed in other states around the nation. But
President Biden is the duly elected president,
and we're going to do everything we can to work
with him to help the citizens of Mississippi.
There are lots of states that Trump won where
there's mail in voting, including Florida,
including Ohio, including Utah. I hear you saying
Joe Biden is the president. I do not hear you
saying he was legitimately elected. FBI Director
Chris Wray, former Attorney General Bill Barr,
have both stated there was no widespread voter
fraud, none that could have affected the outcome
of the November election. Republican after
Republican Deucy in Arizona camp in Georgia,
your colleagues, judge after judge, have
rejected this, rejected this argument.
This is a dangerous conspiracy theory that tens of
millions of people believe and inspired a domestic
terrorist attack on the Capitol. Yes or no? Do
you accept that the 20 20 presidential election
was free and fair? Obviously, every election
has some questions, but I'm talking about
free and fair, legitimately
elected Joe Biden. Yes or no?
As you said, Jack, every election has some
questions, and this one was no different.
President Biden is the duly elected
president of the United States. He was
certified by all 50 states, either having
won or lost. He lost my state by 20 points,
but he was certified in each of the individual
states. He was certified by the US Congress and
he is the newly elected president. All right. That
doesn't mean that we don't have bad laws on the
books in other states. It's just a fact.
This is their new refrain. When asked,
they say Joe Biden is the president. That is
very different than Joe Biden, actually. One,
they are still going with
this. They can't simply say,
despite always having some anecdotal individual
allegations of irregularities in every election,
the number of alleged irregularities wouldn't
come anywhere close, even if they were all
proven to be true to effecting who won. And yes,
of course, Joe Biden won. He says that, well,
oh, you know, I mean, listen, Joe Biden is
president, but there were irregularities. And
Bubba Bubba busts for months, guys for
months. And if they're still saying it now,
they aren't going to stop anytime soon.
I expect them to continue with this
all the way through to the twenty, twenty
four presidential election. And in fact,
they'll use it to try to justify continuing
to suppress the vote as we already see them
doing more than two hundred and fifty Republican
bills in more than 40 states, making it harder to
vote. So let's continue our tour of what has been
happening with Republicans and right wing media
over the last day or two. While Democrats were
passing covid relief over on Maria Bartiromo Fox
News show, she invited on Senator Lindsey Graham
to talk about, of course, trans women in sports.
Hey, listen, at least it's not Dr. Seuss. Here's
Lindsey Graham Way with a distinction between
being a man and woman in the law. Biological boys
are going to start playing and girls sports. And
if you're a religious organization out there and
your faith dictates that certain things happen,
this bill takes that ability. Now, I've talked
about how trans women in sports is a calculated,
fabricated issue that does exist, but
affects almost no one statistically. But
also this idea from Lindsey about the laws are
going to make our religious beliefs irrelevant.
They are the opposite of our religious
beliefs. Who cares? That's America. We
have separation of church and state. You
can privately believe whatever you want,
but you don't get to point to your holy book and
say this belief of mine from my chosen religion
dictates what the law should be. If you believe
in zoos, if you're a Hellenized and you showed up
and you said we must be allowed to do animal
sacrifices, that's in our beliefs. If you
don't allow that, you're limiting our ability to
practice religion, civil law and government don't
have to allow that. Sorry, guys, you might believe
that, but we have secular government. No can do
secular government shouldn't care what you're
supposed holy book says. Then one more from
Maria Bartiromo. She casually mentions
that we know covid came from a Chinese lab
and of course, we don't know that. Take a listen.
Well, I haven't also heard President Biden say
anything about where the coronavirus originated.
We know it originated in a religion lab.
Imagine that she's criticizing Biden for not
having said. Where the virus came from first,
why does Biden have to weigh in on that? He's
the president, he's not a scientist. The virus
has been around now since, you know, November,
December of twenty nineteen in some way, shape
or form. Why does Joe Biden need to weigh in on
that? On that? And secondly, of course, we don't
know that it originated in a Chinese lab. That's
Maria repeating it as fact when it is not fact.
And then lastly, again, as Democrats were passing
covid relief here is radical Republican Trumpy and
Congresswoman Lauren Bobert on Fox News trying
to make the case that I guess what she's saying
is that undocumented immigrants are drunk driving
and they're not being punished or something like
that cause they want to jail you for not wearing
a mask, but want to keep illegal aliens who are,
I don't know, drunk driving here in our country.
Lauren Bobert, who will talk about more in a
moment. Clearly not understanding how immigration
law works in many states and jurisdictions. If
you are drunk driving and you are arrested, local
police don't conduct immigration investigations.
Local police, if you're drunk driving, deal with
the drunk driving, whether you are here illegally
or not. They don't involve themselves in that.
The the the idea of they want to keep them in the
country couldn't be more deceptive and dishonest.
So that's right wing media during the weekend,
a weekend in which we scaled up vaccination and
did nearly eight million doses in three days
past one point nine million in covid stimulus
in the Senate, which now goes back to the House.
This is what they focused on. What value
do they provide? What are they bringing to
the table? It seems as though it's nothing,
but it's actually something very important.
They are providing a parallel agenda setting that
is useful to those who want to continue living
in this alternate reality. And, you know,
Biden most popular initial approval of any
president in 30 years. People want covid
relief and it passed. People increasingly
want the vaccines and they're scaling them
up. You need a parallel story to tell.
And increasingly, it's a story about trans women
in sports, council culture and undocumented
immigrants. That's the story they've done. And now
let's talk a little bit more about Lauren Bobber.